so
[Music]
it's seven o'clock i'm dermott monahan
you're watching sky news tonight and a
special program on a day of travel
disruption
coming up
the biggest railway strike in 30 years
cuts services and causes transport pain
for millions of people
britain's biggest cities see an increase
in congestion but not perhaps as much as
many had feared
an opportunity for those who can to work
from home as office is empty and the
number of people in city centers falls
as more unions threaten to strike we
look at what it might cost to meet their
demands over public sector pay
[Music]
a very good evening it's been a day when
train services were crippled and the
roads congested more than usual but
there are questions about whether
today's rail strikes actually caused the
level of overall disruption that many
had predicted footfall in major towns
and cities was down suggesting a lot of
people ditched the commute and reverted
to working from home once again that of
course
brings consequences fewer people
spending means less money flowing into
the economy so over the next hour we're
going to be looking at the cost that
that brings and also try to assess what
impact meeting the pay demands of the
strikers might have on the economy but
with the story of the day so far here's
our business correspondent paul kelso
the only arrivals at manchester victoria
this morning came under their own steam
there were no trains to disturb the
peace the station shut down almost
completely on day one of the first
national rail strike in 30 years
it's just after eight at manchester
victoria it's peak rush hour well not
this morning the only service running at
all is the tram serving the city usually
this will be full of passengers coming
in and out of leeds and liverpool but
today
there's nothing
it was a similar picture across the
country with london underground shut
down fewer than 20 percent of overground
services running anywhere and large
chunks of the country cut off to the
inconvenience of many there's no way i
work from home i have to get to work but
now that everything has been disrupted
you know at the end of the day the end
goal is to get better pay in better
conditions and if this is what we have
to do and and i support the workers
then then that's what has to be done
we're going to cambridge tomorrow to see
a building um
we're going to go by train but we're
going to drive now working people have
the right to stand up for themselves and
if they don't feel that they're being
offered
the right deal then i think every
anybody's got the right to to strike as
up to 50 000 rmt members walked out in a
dispute over paying conditions the blame
game resumed the prime minister
suggesting commuters should expect a
long haul we need the union barons to
sit down with net network network rail
and the train companies and and get on
with it and uh we need i'm afraid
everybody and i say this to the to the
country as a whole and we need to get
ready to to stay
the course grant chaps can come to the
table if he wants i'm not particularly
bothered but if he wants to come to the
table he'd be welcome as long as he
comes in a framework of goodwill what he
needs to do really is allow the
management of the train operating
companies and network rail the license
to get on with negotiating but while
there was disruption fears this solstice
strike would be the longest day for
travellers two were unfounded
transport for greater manchester say
road traffic was up just two percent
despite eighty percent of trains being
cancelled primed by the pandemic this
was the day millions stayed at home at
this environmental consultants kobit
accelerated a culture of flexible
working so when the strike was announced
they knew what to do it hasn't really
affected me today i'm working from home
i've chosen to work from home today so
it's pretty easy for me to just log on
as i did through the pandemic working
from home
talks between network rail and the rmt
will resume on wednesday but services
will remain disrupted ahead of further
strikes that will come at a price for
city centre businesses and test public
patience and the appetite for compromise
paul kelso sky news in manchester
look at the details four-fifths of all
trains were cancelled today at nine
o'clock this morning only six percent of
the usual services were running the rail
strikes have also had an impact on
traffic on the roads during the morning
rush hour in london the time needed to
make journeys by car was about 26 longer
than those on previous tuesdays at the
same time
but many have opted to work from home as
you've been hearing in manchester
traffic was only two percent higher than
the last two tuesdays
so in london strike action not only hit
overground rail services but also the
underground as well the tube it
contributed to journey times in london
being hit more than anywhere else many
of the city's workers were able to
revisit their lockdown working
arrangements and log on from home but
for others that of course wasn't
possible as either bennett now reports
working from home is not an option for
tanya she's a care manager whose
patients rely on her and her team seeing
them at home
we'll have to provide their personal
care
prepare their meals
get them out of bed
there's absolutely no way that they can
go on today without us being there
so without public transport tanya's
husband has become chauffeur for the day
crisscrossing west london to collect
carers like thai and deliver them to
appointments
they don't realize how many
um is essential workers that actually
get affected by it
as well as the logistical headache
there's a financial one too with fuel
costs congestion charges and extra hours
for carers
i really hope that it doesn't go on for
much longer because we can't go on like
this the carers will start getting tired
after a few days it's too much they've
got families
far too much for many school children
too with exams taking place regardless
harriet and emmanuella were sitting
a-level religious studies and took over
an hour to get to college in east london
it's really stressful because you want
to be focusing on your revision instead
of like
getting to school on time no electronic
devices such as financial music but as
the exam started one of their friends
still hadn't arrived leading to an
anxious weight at the school gate we are
hoping that she makes it through the
gate uh by the way
and the clock is ticking
the student eventually arrived 25
minutes late by no means ideal
preparation good luck
remote working has definitely diminished
the impact of this strike but it's not
just commuters who are affected and it's
not just this week with warnings of
knock-on effects to come long after the
transport system goes back to normal
this gp surgery in croydon is braced for
a flurry of patients seeking new
referrals after missing hospital
appointments a stretched service coming
under further strain we know that in a
couple of weeks time there will be that
inevitable swell of patients who were
unable to attend their appointments
weren't able to get their
investigations done and there will be
that massive swell of administrative
work
that comes to us
a strike confined to the railway but
with consequences far and wide iva
bennett sky news
how much of scotland in wales had to do
without rail services all together today
scotrail cancelled 90 of its services
cutting off large parts of the nation
and laura bundock spent the day seeing
how the disruption hit those in the
likes of glasgow and dundee and sent
this report
glasgow central and scotland's busiest
station almost empty no rush at rush
hour in fact very few chancing commutes
i take just train and it's faster for me
it's easier it's more comfortable and so
if they're not working it's
going to be very stressful for me
because of coverd we've had the work
from home so i don't think it's going to
be as destructive as what it could have
been so i don't think it will have too
much of an impact
90 of trains have been cancelled
alice bought a ticket but was going
nowhere she's freelance and won't get
paid so i usually get the train to work
at 22
nine
and i'm not getting it today so
that's that that is what it is
passengers had been warned to stay at
home with a skeleton service and no
trains north of falkirk the strike hit
scotland hard
scotrail staff aren't actually part of
this dispute but without network rail
staff they can't run trains which is why
there are only five routes operating
across the whole of scotland in aberdeen
not one commuter but several stranded
tourists i'm trying to catch my flight
back to the us i think there's a flight
that'll go through dublin so
that's the backup plan i'm hoping to get
to my friend in london but i'm not sure
if the trains will work there either
the trains certainly weren't working at
dundee and neither were the taxi drivers
i'll stay for a bit longer but if it's
not going to work they might as well
just go home here
because it's just a bit silly is it
really passengers for the ten past
twelve performed it was busier on the
buses
alan and jane are just back from a
scottish isle cruise here we are on
board the ship
nice calm weather but their journey home
now the longest leg
we took advantage of the cruise
line liner bringing us to
glasgow central station
but of course no trains so we decided
we'd
travel back to aberdeen on the bus
most people stayed away resigned and
ready for the strike that brought
scotland's stations to a standstill
laura bunduck sky news glasgow
well of course the strikes have affected
many other areas right across the united
kingdom as in other major cities in
liverpool the lack of trains saw an
increase in other forms of public
transport and taxi services being used
services on merseyrail avanti northern
and transpanine have all been disrupted
while stir for staff at mercy rail
aren't taking part in the industrial
action the operator says because network
rail staff operate the signaling systems
it is unable to provide any trained
services on strike days
and people in wales are dealing with the
biggest rail strike for 30 years with
less than 10 percent of services running
no trains are running west of cardiff or
north of method tidville on any of these
strike days
but some travelers going into london
remain hopeful about the situation
two years ago we booked to go and see
yes at the albert hall and due to
covered and people dying it's been
kicked down the road twice
and of course the day that they choose
to play is the day of the uh rail strike
which we're looking forward to actually
aren't we we're very optimistic that
it's all going to run smoothly and in
fact we're quite enjoying the peace and
quiet so thank you mr rmt and mr lynch i
believe
well the strikes certainly going to
dominate tomorrow's papers we'll have
our press preview and news review from
half past 10 this evening with tonight's
news and tomorrow's papers headlines as
well joining us will be the columnist
with the eye newspaper ian dunt and
anita boteng broadcaster and former
conservative special adviser you're
watching sky news tonight coming up next
your questions on the travel disruption
answered by our panel of experts do join
us for that
[Music]
the world seems to be becoming more and
more divided issues around politics
culture the pandemic are resulting in
vastly opposing viewpoints causing real
risks between us
i want to get in the middle of those
debates i want to better understand
where each stance comes from and whether
there's room for compromise
your knee tremor phillips as we look to
find common ground on sky news
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
they've pushed the protesters further
back here there's around two or three
hundred still remain
i'm dan whitehead and i'm sky news's
west of england correspondent
[Music]
this fan goes on to the streets of
plymouth seven days a week 365 days a
year these facilities are at the moment
a lifesaver results all we've got
[Music]
from fishing communities to bustling
cities we spend every day reporting from
across the region hearing from people
who have real stories
i have nowhere to live for
about three or four months
there are still people inside the
properties here
they're coming from the epicentre of
what is now a global health pandemic
we were seeing and speaking to young
women who were selling themselves right
on the high street it was desperately
sad and the fact it was happening right
in the hearts of this community
before brexit these oysters were being
exported to the eu but the trade stopped
overnight
what's your feeling about the future
blake
i'd all be
finished i don't know
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
welcome back well as promised we're
going to use the next half an hour or so
to try to answer your questions about
the travel disruption particularly on
the railways across the united kingdom
our panel tonight is the conservative mp
and member of the transport select
committee and former member of the rnt
it should be said chris loader we have
the travel editor of the sun newspaper
lisa minnow and the chief economist with
kpmg isle cellphone very good to see you
all thank you very much indeed we've had
lots of questions arranging right over
the subject matter so let's dive
straight in on this one and a very
simple question i'm going to put this to
you lisa um because it's a simple
question but it's more complex than it
seems isn't it it is why are rail
workers striking what are they striking
for because of course it's not just
about pay that's what people kind of
concentrate on
no it's not just about pay this is about
the conditions um that they're working
at pensions and on top of that it's
about whether or not certain jobs are
going to be no longer required in the
modern new railway um service that the
government is trying to actually put
forward they're saying that actually
some jobs that are currently being done
by staff including network rail staff
and um train company staff no longer
needs to be done by
actual people and a lot of it could be
automated and that is something that is
really you know ringing alarm bells with
the um the unions they're saying that
safety should be the first issue and
that that's part of the reason why
they're on strike so yes it's pay uh but
it's also about you know conditions
working conditions for jobs and on top
of that pensions and then whether or not
these roles are going to be you know
going on into the future or whether
these roles are going to be made
redundant and whether that's going to
impact them and have job losses as a
result yeah a huge number of issues
there which is why um the talks and the
negotiations were going on so long and
that's our our next question following
on from that chris loader
why doesn't the government hold talks
with the companies immediately to
resolve these issues as the department
of transport own some of the companies
and this of course is something as you
know that um the opposition have been
calling for you know cut out the
middle management so to speak and you
know go to the government it's the
government after all that holds the
purse strings ultimately
so in these sorts of situations
employees and employers have their
discussions and their negotiations
we have 13 train operators involved with
this we have network rail
totaling roughly 40 000 staff from or 14
different organizations um
each organization has a different set of
terms and conditions
um has different salaries and so on and
so the negotiation
is it is right in my opinion that that
takes place with the employer in the
regular way
it's very clear from my perspective
though that
as time goes on
this is becoming more and more
ideological and that is ultimately why i
believe that the rmt wants to
bring this
to a head with the government
and as it stands at the moment if we
just turn the clock back maybe less than
a month um the result of the strike
ballot was on the 24th of may that was
two days before pay talk started for a
good number of
uh the organizations that are involved
with this so
from my perspective what we've seen is
the rmt jumped the gun quite a bit here
um
they have not um they have not completed
wherefores and as we say these
discussions negotiations have been going
on for an awful long time they're very
complex they involve a lot of issues we
get all that but it's i suppose this
question gets to the nub of it
ultimately if more money is involved and
more money will be involved if there's a
pay rise and indeed for the any
reorganization that takes place the
government ultimately holds the purse
strings it puts billions upon billions
as you know better than all of us into
the railways well it does now but it
didn't before the pandemic
so the operating part of the railway
what we call wash his face so so it
didn't require public subsidy it was
over the period of the pandemic
where it's we saw 16 billion pounds have
to be invested in the railway to keep it
going
the first quarter alone was three and a
half billion
um and as a result of the pandemic we
have seen passenger numbers passenger
journeys have have not returned to their
levels they're 75
passenger revenues a little over a half
so
the real issue here is the lack of
passenger revenue uh here rather than um
taxpayer funds okay well let's talk more
about the the pay rise as i say that i
suppose that the headline issue the one
that's a lot of people have grasped and
our next question addresses that and
yell self in um i mean you know to put
this into overall context i suppose in
terms of the the economy and of course
the inflationary background to these
talks and so many others uh the question
is says i can't understand how a five to
seven percent pay rise is so unrealistic
given that what inflation is now am i
correct nine percent forecast to go to
11 so the pay demand is actually under
the rate of inflation
yes it is um but what we have seen
generally is that pay increases have
been
lower than the rate of inflation we've
seen an average uh pay of around four
percent uh with
some of the private sectors seeing some
price increases on average of around six
percent for example in the hospitality
sector
um with others um in business services
and the likes slightly lower at around
five percent with
on average public sector workers only
gaining around 1.8
increase so we've seen a very varied um
distribution of wage increases and
generally below inflation what we need
to bear in mind is that inflation at the
moment is very high
um
businesses are under quite a lot of
pressure in terms of the margin in terms
of the overall cost
and with the constraint on supply chains
etc it's not always that easy for them
to pass on that increase in cost when
overall consumers are under pressure as
well when it comes to
their spending power
crucial
in terms of when it comes to um to uh
pay demands the future outlook
is that it will go back i mean the bank
of england seem to be suggesting it will
go back to around the 2 mark in what 18
months time is that just sticking their
finger in the air and hoping rather than
any deep inside knowledge
well this is the expectation of most
export economies so if you look at our
focus and they're based on our modeling
and that's like any other economies
we're expecting inflation to start
moderating quite significantly from the
middle of next year and to reach the
bank of england target by
the second quarter of 2024 so that is a
fairly
fast deceleration in inflation we are
expecting the sharp increases especially
in energy prices to fall from the
year-on-year um calculation equilibrium
of inflation
by um
the middle of next year largely so this
is probably
the estimation of most of economists and
and it is crucially based on the hope
that you're not going to get that sort
of price wage spiral so you get rise
wages the rising wages and escalated to
a rising prices and then again
we've seen that
moving um freely all the time that
dynamic it's no longer down to an
external shock that is what the bank of
england is trying
to
prevent
by controlling its inflation expectation
and by hoping that we will have this one
of inflationary shock and that's it okay
so that's the inflationary background
and potentially the outlook um specific
question for you lisa minnow another
member of the public asks this another
straightforward one how safe is it to
travel tomorrow and i guess behind that
question is uh not about physical safety
but about the idea that there will still
be disruption in spite of it not being a
strike day
yeah i mean unfortunately there is going
to be an impact into tomorrow um with
the network rail um you know signalers
particularly being part of this strike
and there will not be people sort of
going into the night so services will
literally be running from about 6 30
tomorrow morning now that's much later
than normal and normally it's a lot more
you know it's a lot earlier in the
morning that services would start and
signals would be there on the job so
that is going to mean that probably
about 60 percent of the you know some
network rail and services will but still
be impacted in the morning i would say
but i hopefully by lunchtime and
particularly in london where you know
trains aren't having to go very long
distances to actually get to where they
need to be and it should actually sort
of quicken up and you should actually
get much better services you know early
on in the morning i would say but there
is still going to be an impact from
first thing i would say and up to 60
could still be impacted across the
country tomorrow okay thanks for that
lisa chris uh here's a question why
isn't the nationalization well
renationalization i guess of the rail
networks an option because you know the
model's already changed from the
original privatization model
i didn't think this strike was meant to
be about the uh pros and cons of
nationalization um although i suspect
some of those on the opposition side
to run the whole thing well i think i
think
instead of all these different train
operators we discussed about the
negotiations before and all these
different layers of management and
quangos you've just got the railway yeah
there's a couple of imports there's a
couple important things just to know um
rail privatisation since the early 90s
has injected
enormous
private investment it has doubled uh
passenger numbers during that time it
has really grown the railways in a way
we have not seen uh in our lifetime what
we saw um through the pandemic though
was a huge shock to the industry
uh which meant that
passenger numbers passenger demand was
impacted hugely i remember
during the peak of the pandemic
passenger numbers were something like
eight or nine maybe ten percent of what
they were expected uh to be
so um
the situation we're faced with now it is
debatable that whether some including
the unions want to use this as a vehicle
to renationalize the railways
it's my opinion that that's not the
right thing to do
the railways as i've as i've just
outlined have grown hugely but the
government has also put forward um only
a matter of months ago plans to change
the structure of the railway to make it
better to improve some of the key issues
of which passengers have experienced and
to deal with some of the complexities in
privatisation that in some cases started
to outweigh the strengths of the
previous model okay
great questions some great answers from
you all thank you very much indeed we're
going to take
a break now and plenty more of these
questions coming your way
after the break we're going to be asking
amongst other things how other public
sector workers could also demand pay
increases and the implications therefore
for the overall economy
[Music]
the plan is to take the political
temperature midweek so we'll be
discussing the biggest stories of the
week so far talking about what's still
to come having a look at prime
minister's questions of course and
getting reaction from politicians plus
our very own viewers and we'll have
analysis from my sky news colleagues the
take with sophie ridge on sky news
[Music]
welcome back to sky news tonight and
this program about today's travel
disruption and that to come well it's
not just of course rail workers who are
angry about levels of pay and their
working conditions unions representing
amongst other things teachers nurses
refuge collectors and barristers have
all said that they may strike as well
and many others as well and today a
union representing 115 000 postal
workers said it was going to ballot
members about possible strike action uh
data and economics editor ed conway has
been looking at what it might cost the
government to deliver better pay for the
public sector
as the cost of living crisis intensifies
there's likely to be more in the way of
industrial action with inflation quite
so high but let's just have a look back
at the history of strikes going all the
way back uh a century or so this shows
you the number of days lost to strike so
the higher the bars are the more strikes
basically there have been and look 2011
the last year when there were lots of
public sector strokes it's actually not
that high is it nowhere in comparison
with for instance 1970s there's the
winter of discontent 1979 or indeed
looking all the way back to 1926 that
incredibly high bar there that's the
general strike really just unprecedented
level of disruption for the uk economy
back then and consider
what we might be going into now in this
year you're talking about public sector
pay a lot of focus on that and a lot of
focus on whether it's kept track with
private sector pay these bars show you
how much they've increased over the past
22 years or so so going back to the
millennium you can see private sector
public safety both have gone up quite
considerably but here's the thing now
let's just look back to 2010 and it's a
different story so since 2010 private
sector pay up by 4.3 inflation adjusted
public sector paid down by 4.3 inflation
adjusted and that's why a lot of people
are saying there needs to be more given
to public sector workers right now but
the question of course is how much can
the chancellor afford this shows you how
much is spent in total by the public
sector so total public spending just
over a trillion pounds
here is public sector pay pay review
bodies so split up between pay review
bodies and non-pay review bodies and if
you kind of add them both up you get to
about 230 billion pounds so what we're
going to do is we're going to take that
slice 230 billion pounds we'll put that
over there and we'll work out how much
it costs to increase it in line with
inflation so first of all the inflation
that the government thought we were
going to be getting two to three percent
that would cost an extra seven billion
pounds or so but of course inflation is
far higher than that it's running at
about nine percent or expect it to be
nine percent this year and if you're
going to write it raise it in line with
that you're talking about 21 billion
pounds and the difference between those
two things it comes out at about 14
billion pounds 14 billion pounds what's
that amount to well if we take that
slice and just put it over there let me
compare it to a couple of things first
of all it's about the same as cutting
income tax all of the main rates of
income tax by two percent which is
precisely what this government would
like to do it comes to about the same
amount raised by the health and social
care levy and you know how controversial
that was so it just underlines it the
chancellor's got some difficult
decisions to make in the next few months
is it going to be inflation rises in for
the public sector is it going to be tax
cuts it's going to be a really
interesting period for economic policy
interesting one we're putting it ed
conway there our data and economics
editor well our panel of experts is
still here with me we have let me
reintroduce them to the conservative mp
and member of the transport select
committee and former member of the rmt
chris lowder travel editor of the sun
lisa minnow and chief economist at kpmg
yael selfin uh very good to see you all
again and plenty more questions sent to
us by sky news viewers and listeners
some
this one is about i suppose some of the
issues that ed conway was addressing uh
if boris johnson wants a high-wage
economy surely a 9
increase would support this i'll get the
economic picture in a moment with the al
selfin but uh chris loader you know we
heard boris johnson last year that was
all the talk at the conference wasn't it
a high-wage economy well you know what's
wrong then with some pretty big pay
increases
well i don't think that uh
proper pay increases or adequate pay
increases in this respect have been
ruled out this is the whole point you
know the the strikes that we are faced
with today on the railways
um
means that the majority of those
businesses that we just outlined have
not actually concluded their paid their
pay negotiations or paid discussions
so i think this whole topic area uh we
run the risk of sort of jumping the gun
with it because i don't think we have a
firm proposal on the table um where
unions can say actually i fully disagree
with with that so i don't think that is
the case what do you think the
government should say in this particular
dispute well the government thinks okay
well you know five to seven percent
that's not bad as long as then we get uh
the reform and the reorganization as
well
no i don't think that because i think
the complexity of the railways means
that you have to be very clear about
what those other things are
you know so for example different parts
of the railway will have a 34 or 35 hour
working week other parts of the railway
will have a 42 hour working week but
maybe there are um other terms and
conditions that affect those so i think
it needs to be done in the round and
that's why the full conversation is
required before we jump into strike
action okay uh yeah itself in that issue
of uh this question is suggesting
something like a nine percent increase
that's a bang on the inflation number as
we've discussed
at the moment so i mean clearly a
high-wage economy i mean everyone wants
to see that but
doesn't it require then productivity
increases to allow us to have it
well absolutely so there's a number of
issues here one is if you want to keep
everything equal if you like if you want
to get higher pay you probably need to
produce more for it otherwise things
cost more so if they cost more it means
that it it people then have to pay more
for them so it's just higher inflation
essentially or you need to if it's in
the case of public sector essentially
you need to increase taxes in order to
pay for that uh unless you start cutting
services
okay well thank you very much and if
that lisa minnow we've got uh this one
again about the knock-on effects
uh of the strike on the days right
before and after strike days the
question asks how serious should we
expect those to be
on the tube that of course is in london
and on inter-city rail services just um
give us your view once again
i mean i think there is going to be
disruption that you know there's no way
of getting around that um but it
definitely won't be anywhere near as bad
as what we've seen today i mean this is
you know the first major strike like you
know that we've seen in this sense for
30 years yes there is going to be issues
tomorrow but i would imagine that you
know genuinely you know after the
morning rush hour tomorrow there should
hopefully be you know a correction and
service is starting to get back up and
running um but saying that you know my
particular rail um company is thameslink
they haven't actually had strike um
staff strike action this week they voted
against it in terms of their own staff
members um but unfortunately because of
network wear and the fact that all of
the train operating companies require
network rail and to run the railways in
the way that they do and they are still
impacted then unable to put on the
services they want and it's a major
commuter route into london so i think
there's going to be an impact throughout
the week and we're going to see you know
far less services than we would normally
expect and those services when they do
come in are going to be very busy got uh
another question then about um the pay
demands and i want to turn this question
around ever so slightly and put it to
you y'all selfing the question is why do
rails staff feel they can strike when
other business sectors are also not
seeing any pay increases and uh let me
ask you about that i mean what is
happening with both public sector pay we
know that there are many pay review
bodies looking at that what's happening
in the private sector at the moment what
what's the overall rate of increase well
i suppose it's a it's a decrease in
actual fact when it's inflation adjusted
yeah absolutely so across the board we
see across all sectors
a real hit on pace so it is very rare on
average for sector to see a rise in
nominal
wages that is higher than the
unprecedented almost um increasing
inflation that we have at the moment and
therefore we have a real decline across
the board it's just a question of how
bad it is
for different industries with some
especially those with um higher vacancy
rates um seeing slightly higher nominal
pays and others um seeing slightly lower
the heat a bit more but we also need to
take things in perspective in a slightly
longer term perspective and also look at
other things like other conditions
that people have some people have higher
pensions or different type of pensions
that is more favorable than others so so
the overall pay package is not there's a
whole package that some employers have
we probably need to compare a little bit
more in terms of the overall conditions
as well okay very good point um back to
the the rail workers specifically uh
chris loaded this i suspect um coming
from a rail worker says not all rail
workers are on 46 000 i think that's the
kind of average figure
that's been given i'm not i struggle to
pay my bills can i have assurance my job
is safe and this is part of the
negotiations isn't it no compulsory
redundancies
so
over the past year or a little bit
longer than that the railways have been
running a voluntary redundancy program
that has been hugely over subscribed
i think as part of a negotiation and or
settlement
a reopening of that voluntary redundancy
programme will enable that very point to
happen
um
i'm clearly not close enough to know the
numbers and and and so on but
um i think we're in this in the
situation where
i mean i can't recall the last time
compulsory redundancies
uh were put forward for um frontline
grade groups in the railways i can't
recall it
i would be very surprised if that were
as part of a final negotiation agreement
but of course that is where we will need
to get to because at the end of the day
despite all the difficulty we're
experiencing now there will be an
agreement at the end of the day
but then you're saying it can all happen
through so-called natural wastage but
you always get that happening not
necessarily in the areas
you wanted to so you end up with a
reorganization at the very least i'm not
quite talking about natural racist
wastage and natural attrition i'm
talking about that you know since the uh
end of the
the really impacting part of the
pandemic passenger numbers have been
down considerably the yields of those
journeys have been down overall revenue
has been roughly just under two-thirds
of what it was before the industry has
already taken some steps and they found
in that process that their voluntary
redundancy programs were hugely over
subscribed so i'd be surprised if we get
that part okay because um another um
broader economic question so uh
cellphone strikes are poorly timed after
the announcement of crippling living
expenses we know the cost of living
crisis uh small businesses struggling
and empty food banks and can i add a
huge demand for them how can we earn a
living and reduce economy if we can't
get to work post code covet i i mean
will this have uh
another economic effect if it is only
this week of strikes
well i mean it will have some impact the
good news is that a big chunk of the
population can now work from home we're
well worse without and and therefore it
should have a more limited impact um in
that regard and also the other good news
is that these are just specific days so
unlike the lockdown that we had earlier
that was much more prolonged with this
this time around if we were having an
appointment to the hairdresser or we
were going to go out we could just do it
another day
during the week or next week and
provided there's still space for us we
can still do that delayed
consumption so hopefully small
businesses will be less impacted this
time around than during the lockdown
that we had early on
here is hoping i think this might have
to be the last question so at least i'm
going to put it to you we've been asked
an awful lot of people asking about
tomorrow and friday what about further
down the line excuse the pun can we
expect rail services to be back to
normal
next week i suppose that's slightly how
long's a piece of string we don't know
whether the talks are going to resume
and uh how much progress they may make
but um there aren't any planned strikes
next week are there
no there are no planned strikes next
week so i mean as you said is a bit of a
how long is a piece of string we need to
see um whether or not the train
companies are going to be able to sit
down with the unions and actually work
something that will actually be
something that they can bring back to
their members and we would possibly see
perhaps if those you know talks fail
again similar type of strike action as
we've seen this week so days at a time
and with gaps in between because um i
think for the unions they've discovered
that that's actually one of the more
sort of the better ways for them to have
an impact because if they do it over two
separate days with space in the middle
there's still going to be an ongoing
impact in those days in the middle and
so we'd hope that they can come to some
kind of resolution but there is every
chance this possibly could rumble on
into the summer yeah i mean just this
dispute chris lowder your thoughts on
that just this dispute the rmt dispute
but of course we know that uh the
trained drivers who actually aren't
involved in this dispute represented by
azlef that they're balancing on strike
action it could go on and the prime
minister was saying it today could go on
for a long time couldn't it
train drivers with an average salary 57
000 pounds
um and i think
it's this sort of thing this
coordination
of industrial action
that gives me
real doubt as to the genuine motives
behind
these strikes you're absolutely right
the mandate which was given to
the rmt by its members on the 24th of
may will go forward for six months so
it's you know the end of end of november
um
i suspect we are in for a pretty bumpy
time um it feels to me that the trade
unions are coalescing
and aligning in order to have a
fairly considerable
um
fair yeah fairly considerable ideologies
the government will get involved
well i think this is got to bear in mind
the dispute when it comes to the
railways
is with employers
we have goes on and on but well
i'm just trying to think you know what
what can the government solve which the
employers
can't now
the fact that you know i don't know the
other um
other professions and other grade groups
to understand their concerns or issues
and so on but
i think that there is a
real need to sort out the genuine issues
and concerns
with the employers about because you
know the unions tell us it's not just
about pay there are other things as well
they need to be sorted out and trying to
build this into an enormous
spat ideological spat is not the way to
do that okay well listen thank you all
we are out of time thank you all very
much indeed for your time chris loader
lisa minnow and yale selfie very good to
see you all and thank you very much
indeed for sharing your huge expertise
and knowledge with us all here on sky
news tonight
and you're watching sky news tonight
we're coming up next we're going to be
staying with that issue and uh looking
at it from labour's perspective how
would the opposition handle the strike
i'll be talking to the shadow attorney
general emily thornbury
[Music]
situation is not huge chaos uh there is
undoubtedly problems particularly at a
number of uk airports most notably
manchester heathrow and gatwick uh where
the either the airport security or the
baggage handling providers are short
staffed that is causing pinch points but
it's important to keep some context here
1995 of all flights are getting away
they are delayed by atc and airport and
handling delays but they are getting
away people are getting to their
destinations some airlines are
cancelling a small proportion of their
flights between five and ten percent
which is deeply regrettable but this is
one of the uh the byproducts of the
struggle to recover smoothly from two
years of covered lockdowns and
government mismanagement over there
completely to do with brexit i mean an
awful lot of these pinch points would be
uh resolved very quickly and very
rapidly if we could bring in european
workers to do the jobs that frankly
people in the uk are not applying for
and don't want to do
uh this has always been the way the uk
has uh provided our uh man that staffed
his transport industry
and it is the way forward if the and if
we can't
attract people to do those jobs like
baggage handling like security at the
airports we're going to have to bring in
workers whether it's from ireland or
from the continental europe to do them
and brexit is one of the big bug bears
in the system it has introduced enormous
labor market inflexibility in the uk and
there are hundreds of thousands of jobs
in the uk that frankly british workers
don't want to do
i think this problem is going to
continue particularly at those airports
like catholic and heathrow right
throughout the summer i mean it would be
worse at weekends it would be better
during the week uh
there are less problems at airports like
stan said ryanair is operating a full
schedule where fully staffed with pilots
and camper group but even we last
weekend suffered 24 of our flights were
delayed by eight air traffic control
delays another fifteen percent of fights
were delayed by airport and handling uh
delays so i think it is going to be a
struggle through the summer the airlines
uh the uk airlines ba easyjet 2e ryanair
and others we will get 90 95 percent but
well right here we get nearly 100 of our
people to their destinations i will be
with delays
but it will be a less than satisfactory
experience and this problem will not be
resolved until we start allowing
european workers to come in and do the
jobs that frankly uk people no longer
wish to do
welcome back to this special program
covering today's rail strikes the prime
minister said today that people need to
get ready to stay the course suggesting
he believes that industrial action could
last for quite some time and the labour
leader shakir stamina is said to be
considering taking disciplinary action
after several senior labour mps joined
picket lines to support the strikers
well i'm joined now by the labour mp and
shadow attorney general emily thornbury
very good evening to you and before we
discuss the wider issues which we will
in depth just that issue then of a whip
and at least three pps's disobeying the
leader and appearing on picket lines
will they be disciplined
i honestly don't know i mean i would i
would have thought that it was up to
it's up to their immediate bosses the
shadow secretaries of state to speak to
them find out what's going on and i
presume that the uh the whips are going
to be quite interested to know well one
of them was a whip well that's what i
was that's what i've just been told i
mean i don't know the details to be
honest and it's not something i'm good
but
i mean you think it should be delegated
to the lower levels of labour party
management what about the leader who
said himself who put out that memo
saying right you know no shadow
ministers and no pps is on the picket
lines it's pretty clear
well when all of this stuff is a team
sport you know we all have different
roles um and i'm here as the attorney
general and as a member of the shadow
cabinet there's a certain amount of
collective responsibility but i'm not in
charge of discipline so i can't really
help you i'm sorry
you almost sound as if you think they
should be disciplined because many of
you call i'm saying that because many of
your colleagues suggest that they should
not be that this is not the way that
labour should be going
i think that
i think that what we need to be doing is
we need to be focusing on the issue
itself and not falling into traps that
are laid for us by
by this government i think that actually
what's happening is that they are using
this the government is using this as a
wedge issue i think they are trying to
divide everybody up i think they're not
what they're not doing is what a
government ought to be doing in these
circumstances which is pulling both
sides together but also taking a seat at
the table too because i think that at a
time like this we need to have a
strategic view of where we're going with
the railways what government money needs
to go into it and you know what do we
expect post-pandemic where are we going
but instead we have a government that
throws throws petrol on the flames and
uh and just keeps trying to wind the
situation up and shouts labour labour
labour it's all labour's fault i think
we need to step away from that and not
be involved in such in that but actually
be saying to the government this is how
you should be behaving this is what a
sensible grown-up alternative government
thinks you should be doing and look at
the way you are behaving you are not
making matters better you are making
matters worse and i think the idea of
you know some of the more junior members
of uh you know the bag carriers in the
in the shadow team going on the going on
on picket lines is a little bit of a
distraction from that so you know that's
unfortunate but i mean the politicians
but the important thing is that we hold
them to account for for the way in which
they are simply making matters worse and
this won't be okay
okay but i mean you mentioned it being
used as a wedge issue yeah the
governments and there's no doubt many
political commentators agree with you
about that but part of the problem from
labour's point of view is is that you're
allowing that to happen by being so
mysterious about what your position is
on this particular dispute
well we know well we know the demands
right okay is it seven percent do you
support seven percent for railway
workers oh i see no look we can't be at
the table saying this is the solution
with the government yeah if we were the
government that would be a different
matter absolutely we would say in
principle the government should be there
and should be talking to both sides and
we should be talking about what changes
need to be made if any
how many you know what what's a
reasonable amount for staff we need to
have a proper strategic overview of this
and and we just have a government at the
moment who i mean listen we all know who
who who boris johnson has breakfast with
these days he's having breakfast with
you don't know
carrie johnson i suspect all right well
a later breakfast at 8 30 is with linton
crosby and in february of this year in
australia the government there had a had
a rail dispute and instead of getting
involved in sorting it out they spent
all the time using it as a as a tool as
a as a weapon against the labour party
okay
this is the same place we know that that
is your analysis but the problem is as i
say once again is we don't know what
labour's position is do you support the
strike do you because some of your
colleagues have come out and say yes you
know they may not have been on the
picket line but they see why the railway
workers have gone on strike but you said
any strike is a failure a failure by
which side well both sides okay so the
unions have failed tonight has been
saying so the rnt have failed
mick tonight has said that we need to
have it from the rmt he said you know we
need to have an agreement of course we
need to have an agreement so what's your
message to the rnt
is your message to get back to the table
right now tomorrow of course it is and
the and the railway companies and you
know boris johnson don't stop yelling at
people actually you know
make sure you said probably not you but
send someone who's sensible who's
thoughtful who can be involved in the
negotiations and let's sort this out
together that's what we say i think
that's fairly straightforward whose side
are we on we're on the side of the
commuters of the workers who are trying
to get to work you know we understand
that there are circumstances in which
people you know will exercise their
right to strike that's you know of
course
um but you know when it happens it is a
failure it's a failure of negotiation
and you know we need to get back around
well it's happening right now and it's
going to happen again on
are you saying to the rmt don't strike
on thursday call it off
up to that table no no i mean they are
completely within their rights to to
have a strike you know i wish they
wouldn't i wish that there was a an
agreement i wish that this hadn't
happened and i do condemn the government
for not getting involved and instead for
just making matters worse that's that's
my position and i would say this is also
a really important lesson for this
government because we know that there
will be disputes in all sectors
of the economy in the near future in the
public sector too and if this is how
they're going to behave this time then
what are they going to be doing with all
the other disputes that are happening
they really do need to think again that
this is not about wedges this is not
about campaigning this is about being a
grown-up government shadow attorney
general we're out of time thank you very
much indeed for coming along emily
thornbury there and you're watching sky
news tonight coming up at eight o'clock
on the program we'll be looking at how
today's strikes on the railways have
affected people right across the united
kingdom only about 20 percent that
services were able to run stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were